- The one thing I really like
about the LearnStorm activities
is that they introduce students
to the growth mindset concept,
to neural plasticity,
to the fact that the
brain grows and changes.
And they introduce the
importance of effort.
It's really helpful for teachers
to call out and recognize students
when they're putting forth effort.
But it's also really important for them
not to use effort as a
kinda consolation prize.
To say, it's okay that
you didn't learn anything
because you worked hard.
The idea is to really
remind students all the time
that by putting forth effort,
they're really preparing
their brain to grow.
They're really kind of getting
all their pistons in the brain firing,
and that even if they don't
master a particular concept yet,
that the effort,
the intellectual effort they put into it
will eventually pay off
with them kinda preparing their brain
to understand the process
that content over time.
And so it's really important
to not just focus on effort
but to focus on the combination of effort
and using good strategies
to really call attention to the fact that
if you're working really
hard at something,
well, you know, maybe you
should persist for a while
but if it's really,
if you're really spinning your wheels,
it might be more helpful to step back
and to think about is there a
different strategy I can use?
Is there someone I can talk to
to help me think differently
about this particular kind of problem
or this particular concept?
To make sure that the
effort I'm putting in
is actually paying off
with helping me grow that ability.